The entries corresponding
to the different suits are 1/2 for clubs, negative
i over two for diamonds,
zero for hearts because it doesn't appear in the sum and one over square
root of two for spades.
And here's what it looks
like as a column vector, assuming that we've ordered
the classical states as we did before,
which is the order that
you see right here.
Taking the absolute value
squared of these entries gives one quarter for the first one, also one quarter for the next one.
The absolute value squared
of zero is equal to zero, so that entry doesn't
contribute to the sum.
And finally, for the last one, we get 1/2. So the sum is equal to one as is required for this vector
to be a quantum state vector.
Now just a moment ago, we used the notation
ket plus and ket minus to referred to two qubit state vectors that aren't standard basis vectors.
And I'd like to return
to this point briefly and explain how the Dirac notation is used for arbitrary vectors and not just for standard basis vectors.
As I've already mentioned, we can use whatever name we
want inside of a bra or ket to refer to a vector.
Kets are column vectors
and bras are row vectors just like before.
As an example, the Greek letter
psi is very commonly used inside of a ket to refer to some arbitrary vector,
and here, we're using it to
give a name to the state vector from before that doesn't
have a special name.
When we do this, the let our psi doesn't
necessarily have any meaning all by itself.
It's just the name of a vector, and it's inside of a ket to help us to clarify
that it's a column vector.
This can be a little
bit confusing sometimes, and there is a potential for ambiguity if the letter psi could be associated
with a classical state of
some system for instance, but it generally doesn't
cause any problems, and you don't have to use
the Dirac notation like this
if you don't want to. Using a lower case letter such
as u, v, or w without a ket is also a fine way to
denote a column vector
or more specifically,
a quantum state vector.
It's your choice what notation
you use to express yourself.
You just need to make
sure that number one, the meaning of what you
are trying to express is clear to others.
And number two, that you understand what
others are trying to express even when their preferences for notation aren't the same as yours.
There is one very important rule for using the Dirac notation
for arbitrary vectors and that is that if you
have a column vector
that you've decided to write
as ket psi, for instance, or it could be a different
name inside of a ket, then the row vector bra psi
is understood to be
the conjugate transpose of the vector ket psi.
And here, this is written as an equation where this dagger right here refers to the conjugate transpose.
What that is specifically is
the row vector you get by, number one, transposing the vector, meaning that you flip
the vector on its side and you change it from a column into a row
without actually changing the entries. And number two, taking the complex conjugate
of each of the entries.
You can actually perform
those two operations, the transpose and the
entry-wise complex conjugate in either order or those
two operations commute.
So for the vector in this example, given that we've decided to
call this vector ket psi, it's understood that bra psi
means this vector right here
where we've transposed the vector by turning ket zero and ket
one into bra zero and bra one, and we've taken the complex
conjugate of each entry,
which is why one plus
two times i over three turns into one minus two
times i over three right here.
Here's what these vectors look like when they're written
explicitly as a column vector and a row vector.
Notice, by the way, that
this rule is consistent with the notation we use when we have classical states
inside of the bra and the ket.
In that case, the entries are
all zero except for one, one, and so taking the complex
conjugate doesn't do anything in that case.
We've now seen how quantum states are represented as vectors, but it's not clear at this
point what the meaning or the implications are
in terms of what you
can do with the system in a quantum state or how you can interact with it.
The first thing we need to do to bring these issues into focus
is to discuss measurements.
Intuitively speaking,
measurements provide a mechanism for extracting classical
information from quantum systems.
When we look at a system
when it's in a quantum state, we don't see a quantum state just like we don't see
probabilistic states,
we see classical states, and this notion of a measurement is what provides the interface.
If we, as humans, want to know something about a quantum system, we have to measure it, and in doing so, we'll extract classical information
about whatever quantum
state that system was in.
There are different
notions of measurements. The difference is one
of generality really, and we're going to start with the simplest and most basic one,
which is typically called a
standard basis measurement.